Racist Mom,
that was the,
that's like the label they get put on them,
right?
Yeah.
And then you know,
like that was the label that was put on the proud boys almost immediately.
Right.
Yet they're white supremacists.
Even though there was people of color that were amongst the ranks and well they
changed the definition of racist.
Do you know what the whole origin of the proud boys is?
Yes.
It's kind of fucking hilarious.
Up.
Get up.
Go ahead Anthony Kumi.
It told the whole story on this show because it happened with him and,
and Gavin McInnes that Gavin McInnes came up with it because of a guy that
worked there and they were doing it as a goof and then it became a movement and
then became like anybody can join in.
The people that joined,
they took it into a radical way and then it became looking to beat up antifa and
it's just like,
fuck.
Well Gavin's crossed the line.
Yes.
That's,
you know,
there's,
and I'll point it out for your,
uh,
you mentioned media matters in a,
in a recent,
you know,
that you're talking about Alex Jones.
I wouldn't use them as a source for anything.
Well that's a good point.
But it was just clips of Alex talking.
It doesn't matter.
Uh,
they,
there's a,
there's a clip going round of Gavin McInnes where you can hear him saying these
crazy things and you're like,
well,
he said it right.
But it turns out some of the clubs was talking about dogs.
They,
they,
you know,
you really can't take the context out of things and these clips and understand
that.
So what happens if I'm even afraid in my videos,
I don't quote people anymore because people have taken me reading a quote from a
newspaper and attributed to me simply for reading someone else's quote.
And they say,
oh,
but he said it.
Right,
right.
I mean,
you look at the really,
the really funny instance of Count Dracula at the guy with the Nazi pug.
That is a hilarious story.
And they told him context didn't matter.
So when he leaves the courtroom,
the reporter says,
you said this phrase,
which I'm not going to say,
and he says,
so did you,
if context doesn't matter,
right,
you should be arrested too.
But that's,
you know,
so,
so what ends up happening is these activist groups,
they take these quotes out of context,
but,
but admittedly,
I think it's fair to point out a lot of people recognize Gavin,
if you can assume there were jokes or not,
doesn't matter.
He said things that were over the,
over the line.
Well,
Gavin's the main problem,
the indefensible problem was the call to violence,
right?
The calling,
calling for violence.
And I don't think Gavin's like,
he's another one.
He's like a prankster.
He's like a punk rock style prankster.
And he likes to burn it to the ground.
Yep.
And look,
I'm a fan of Gavin's interviews on youtube where he'll,
he hoodwinks people and to sitting down and talking to him,
or I don't even know if they're still up anymore,
but my understanding is he ruined some checks.
Life.
I mean this like somewhat figuratively,
she was a,
a left wing individual.
He didn't know who he was.
He asked her to come on and her friends basically just disavowed her immediately
because she was talking to him because she sounded an unintelligent,
oh,
I gotta you.
Gotta I gotta tell you,
man,
he cornered her.
I don't know if you have this issue,
but for the longest time it's,
it's,
it's substantially harder to interview someone on the ideological left than
anyone else.
Right.
So I recently reached out to,
you know,
I regularly reach out to people.
I don't,
I'm not going to name drop cause I don't want to drag people,
but a man,
it takes weeks trying to organize a meeting with some,
you know,
these personalities who are progressive and on the left.
Yup.
Uh,
even even people who,
like I,
I've gotten messages from people saying,
yeah man,
I watch yourself stuff all the time,
but hold on,
let me,
let me think about it.
And talked to some people first.
And I'm not saying they're doing it because they're,
you know,
skittish or it's just harder.
It's a lot harder.
Well,
they're probably more cautious,
especially if you know your,
where your ideology,
Stan is ambiguous.
It's trying to figure it out.
Oh yeah.
If,
if you're,
you know,
a man,
even,
even Dave and pat,
David Pakman,
Jimmy Dore get get dragged through this sometimes.
I see the people on Twitter calling them all to write the weirdly enough or
intellectual dark web Jimmy Doors.
An interesting character.
I really liked our car.
Yeah,
I think he's such an interesting guy.
He's very smart,
but he's,
he's like,
oh,
he's an angry lefty,
but you know,
but he defends free speech.
He defines question and he's 100% here.
Here's my thing,
man.
I was in Berkeley,
it was this big protest against Ben Shapiro and there's a guy wearing a mask
with a,
you know,
communist flag full like rent gear.
So I got to interview him and I'm like,
you mind if I interview?
He was like,
yeah,
of course.
And I was like,
really?
Oh,
that's surprising.
And then we started talking and I said,
how do you feel about these people that dress in all black and you know,
are,
are fighting people and causing problems?
Oh,
that's terrible.
I was like,
Eh,
you think so?
Really?
It's actually,
I'm surprised because often when I see people wearing,
you know,
fully masked up with communist stuff,
they're typically in favor of the by any means,
by any means necessary strategies.
And he was like,
no way,
man,
that's wrong.
And so I'm like,
you know what man,
I don't care if you're communist,
I don't care if you're whatever,
as long as not an authoritarian who thinks you have the right to beat other
people to instill your ideology on them or use manipulative force or coercion or
extortion like,
so let me,
let me,
let me talk about why I think what we're seeing with Twitter might be one of the
biggest problems ever.
Twitter,
Youtube,
Facebook.
These platforms are where we exist socially,
politically.
It's where our ideas are exchanged.
It's where we learn about who we are going to vote for or why we won't vote for
somebody.
When you band somebody,
you exile them.
They're no longer a part of that conversation.
So they're very much so told you are outside the city walls,
right?
You can't come and you can't talk to us and there's nothing you can do about it.
But then when you realize the rules are actually bent,
you know they're slanted in a certain direction,
you can then predict where things are going.